bea
今から日本語の講座を行います
日本語質疑応答と第6回大公開開始
今までの勉強の中で最も役立ったものはなり以前にも話したことがあるけど
上原亜衣やる気が一番重要だすべての漢字に振り仮名がつい
言えばいいなんでないいい質問だ世の中にまだ希望が残っているからだ
辛いと幸いの感じの区別をつける方法を教えてください
でも簡単だこっちが辛いそしてこっちが幸い
はい実は反対だったこれであんたも一生混乱するに違いない
もっとも感じに適していると大語は何もっとも感じに適していると
がこれがあると感じがだいぶ上手くなるキーボードだ
部首をどうやって勉強したスマホを片手に生きるこの時代に物資なんて勉強したって
時間の無駄だ
まっじゃなくて
感じペットグラフィックスを使えばいい題名のグラフィックスに x が入っている
から本格的なのがわかる口汚い言葉を使わずに素の意味を伝える方法ってある
敬語を使うことだ例えばうるさいって言いたいときは黙れパーカーの代わりにそうで
ございますかといってみてください
必ず感情が伝わる落とし
では茎言葉が上手ばが会話がものすごく苦手だ
例えば待ちましょうの罰っていう感じを見ない限り
意味がわからないどうしたらいい悪い知らせがある不正リックス君
あんたは医学的に入ってろう者なんだ現在園2の四角い家を持っているんですが
感じが全く読めませんこれって大丈夫ですかね
どうやら
カニングをしたようですね
まあ誰にもバレなきゃいいだろう
同市の手の形を簡潔に説明してください
ぐで終わっていればよく間違える活用今に目を通して日本語を勉強している理由とに
なるまでともぐらい時間がかかる
アニメを通してたと
パパだそんなの無理だよごめん今のは冗談だ
戦闘力が10000以上であれば3年間ぐらいか要件ができればにね相槌を適当に打て
ば日本語ができると思われる
これっていつもでどこまで使えるえいえんに使える何しろ日本人もそうしているから
道元のビザの種類は何日本人の違い
っているあ日本人ですなことが付く単語もあれば
のことが付く単語も違いを教えてください
うん a なるほど
ですね yeah
ni
アニメを通してだと思うバカなそんなの無理だよえええ